la situación del presidente pedro
castillo es sumamente complicada porque
la lo vista a karel y lópez lo acusado
ante la fiscalía de dirigir es el
palacio del gobierno de dar una
organización criminal que se encargaría
de cobrar cupos a algunos empresarios
para favorecerlos con licitaciones de
obras públicas la finalidad según el
testimonio de lópez ante la fiscalía
sería obtener dinero para pagar gastos
que se realizaron durante la campaña
presidencial el presidente pedro
castillo ha rechazado estar inmerso en
actos de corrupción y al mismo tiempo ha
acusado a la fiscalía de integrar un
complot para desestabilizar a su gestión
que sería ayer el mandatario había sido
advertido de esta situación por sus
asesores y le recomendaron exponerlo y
es así que el mandatario ha venido
exigiendo la aplicación de la carta
democrática interamericana para defender
a su gobierno